Rồi dân qua, giới sự lãnh đạo của bụ trín trị, đồng trí tổn bị thư tổ lâm, sự điều gành quyết liệt của chính phủ, thủ tương trí phủ,
bụ quốc phòng đã nỗ lực phát triển dụ sản phẩm trong lĩnh bực công nghệ cao.
Công nghiệp quốc phòng theo định gửm tự lực tự trụ, tự cường, lướng dụ, hiện đại.
Bụ quốc phòng đã dòng nghiệp bụ cho tập loạn Việt theo, tiên phòng trong nghiệp kiểu, phát triển công nghệ cao,
bỏ đã thiết kế sản phố thành công chiếp phục vụ công nghệ nằm gờ, tựng bước làm trụ tổn bộ quy trín thiết kế chiếp.
Vực về theo khởi công xe dựng nhà máy chiế tạo chi ban dẫn công nghệ cao tại hù công nghệ cao hoa lạc, chiến dẫn tích,
hà nhi bệnh hết ta, lạc ứng cho các ngành công nghiệp chiến lực của quốc gia, giúp hoàn thiệt và khách kiếm toàn bộ quy trình sản phố chi ban dẫn ngày tại Việt Nam.
Để không chỉ là một dự án đầu tư, mà là một dấu mức chiến lực, thể hiện quyết tâm của Việt Nam tham gia sâu thực chất vào chủi giả trị ban dẫn toàn cao.
Để đặt được các mục tiêu của chính lực phát triển công nghiệp ban dẫn Việt Nam đến năm 2020, tâm nghiệp năm 2020.
Mối cuộc ra đều và trà lời giữ khỏi các bạn, chúng ta đến gần đầu trong trời sát chỉ ban dẫn,
càng cao.
Dúng ta được choa phủ thuộc hay làm trù công nghệ Việt Nam thông đứng ngoài mà không có việc giết dành nào.
Dúng ta được choa con đường khó như khả bệnh bướng.
Tình bức làm trù công nghệ lói, trù đồng tham gia trời cùng những tòa cầu trên cơ sở, hợp tắc bình đàn.
Cùng gó lời, bởi một cái tình đàn là bên phòng bình trò, bên có thể sẽ bên cộng đẹp.
Này ngay có thể.
Bà một cái tình đàn chúng ta dù có gần mấy phòng bý, thì cũng bên mà xà mấy, át đi à đến.
Các cứ chúng ta dạy là như vậy.
Hình này ngay công nghiệp chi bánh dẫn của Việt Nam đã đặt được những kết quả quan trọng.
Hình thành các dưới nghiệp còn lực tự trù thiết kế một số loại chiếp,
cho thành chúc tâm về đống kói, kìm thủ chép, phát triển, hình thành đổi ngủ trên lực đồng côt,
với gần sống in kỹ xưa bánh dẫn, từng bức phát triển hạ tần và ginh kiểu tại các cơ sở giáo dục đại học cho khiến.
Như tập đòn công nghệ lưỡn của thế giới đầu tư, hợp tắc tại Việt Nam.
Ghiều khỏi công nhà mấy chế tỏ chí bánh dẫn công nghệ cào, bần tiên đúng này.
Chúng ta có thể khẳng địch, Việt Nam hoàn quan của thế tình bức là một thủ đất công nghệ cào,
và một mắt xíc quan trọng trong trôi ra chí bánh dẫn tăng cầu.
Tánh dấu của trên mình từ tham ra lắm trủ lắm rấp, sẵn sẵn tạo,
góp phần nâng cao, tiêm lực, bị thế của Việt Nam trong vị vị số qua đỏ thế,
bí nghe, mắt trọng sau đây. Tình bức là một trủ công nghệ lôi, hình thành lực chế tạo chí bánh dẫn công nghệ,
hoàn thiệt tối ra chí và giám vụ thuật mà bình ngoài.
Đám bảo âm linh mà đột tiêm cây công nghệ phát triển công nghệ lướng giống gắn trạm.
Tình tế với có phòng mà anh linh.
Thủ tưởng chính phủ yêu cầu, cần xây dừng hệ xin thái bánh dẫn cuộc ra,
lấy nhà mấy chế tạo lắm hạt nhân để kết nối bánh dạ.
Nhà nước, già dưới nghiệp và nhà khoa học.
Phát triển vụ nhé lực bánh dẫn chất lượng cao, gắn đào tạo với sản xuất,
tạo mua trường để đổi gủ kí xương, chuyên gia Việt Nam trường thành,
làm chủ và sản tạo công nghệ từng bức hình thành các trủi công nghệ sản phẩm dịch vụ công nghệ cao.
Nó độ á chính phủ thu tưởng chính phủ đặc quyết định giáo nhà vụ xây dừng nhà mấy sản xuất,
bánh dẫn đầu tiên, chế vụ cũng phòng.
Và là đơn vị trì em khai là tập đoàn về theo với nềm tin.
Những nào của hành thành có khăn nào của của quà.
Cảy tu nào của đánh thẳng?
Không có việc gì có, thì xa lòng không bàn,
nào nguyên, mà lắm biển, các chiếc, át lòng nên.
Chính lực phát triển công nghiệp bánh giấn Việt Nam đặc ra một tiêu,
đến năm 2020, phần đầu ít nhất một chăm dân nghiệp kết kế chiếp,
phát triển của những lực bánh giấn cả về số lượng và chất lượng,
nào tạo chiến năm, những kỹ xí bánh giấn, phần đầu dân nghiệp công nghiệp bánh giấn
là trên 20% đủ lá một năm, tập trung làm chủ công nghệ loi.
Thủ tưởng yêu cầu tập đoàn về theo tiếp tục làm chủ công nghệ che tạo chiếp
để phục buộc nghiên cứu, thiết kế và sản xuất các sản phẩm công nghệ cao,
thình thành và thuộc đời phát triển hệ xin thái bánh giấn,
nhất là những vực thiết kế chiếp, trở thành chung đâm thực hành,
nào tạo giân lực sản xuất chiếp bánh giấn.